Xin cảm ơn các bạn đến với khóa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube gái Excel bài số
23 các phím tắt thông dụng các bạn xem
Mở cái file này lên các bạn chú ý mình
sẽ để cái link tải file thực hành trong
phần mô tả cái dưới video tốt nhất là
các bạn tải về các bạn vừa theo dõi và
thực hành cùng mình nhá ở đây mình đã
liệt kê tất cả là hai mươi năm phím tắt
thông dụng nhất được đầu tiên sẽ là cái
phím tắt cho cái việc copy để copy thì
các bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà
các bạn muốn copy đúng ạ thì sau đó các
bạn sẽ ấn cần thương c thì sau khi các
bạn ấn cần c thì các bạn sẽ thấy cái
vùng mà các bạn cần copy đây này nó nhấp
nháy đây này Đấy đấy là cái kiếng tắt
cho việc copy nhá những các thứ hai là
Tết hay còn gọi là gián thì sau khi mà
có bạn copy rồi đúng không ạ thì các bạn
phải chuyển cái vùng copy sang một cái
vị trí mới đúng không giả sử mình muốn
coppy cái vùng này sang cái vị trí này
chẳng hạn thế nhá là cái
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ ấn phím cần Xuân V để
các bạn biết cái hiện cái vùng mà các
bạn copy lúc trước đấy thì đây là cái
vùng mà các bạn Tết đúng ạ thì sau khi
mà các bạn ấn convey để có quyết xong
thì cái vùng copy nó vẫn nhấp nháy Đúng
không các bạn sẽ mở mic kết để thoát cái
việc nhấp nháy này phím tắt thứ ba là
cắt đúng ạ chị đầu tiên là các bạn phải
bôi đen Cái vùng mà các bạn cần cắt đúng
không Ví dụ mình đem cái vùng này là
mình muốn cắt đấy thì sau đó các bạn sẽ
bấm phím Control x để các bạn cắt thì
cái vùng mà các bạn cần cắt đây này nó
cũng là nhấp nháy đúng ạ Đấy thì sau khi
mà các bạn cắt xong thì thông thường các
bạn phải chuyển cái vùng cắt sang một
cái vị trí mới có hàng Ví dụ mình cắt
sang đây đúng không thì các bạn lại bấm
thanh xuân về đấy thì sau khi các bạn
bấm cân vị thì cái vùng mà mình cắt Lúc
nãy này nó sẽ không còn dữ liệu nữa đúng
không nó sẽ trở về cái quả trắng thì cái
việc cắt này nó khác gì với cả cái copy
ạ Cái việc copy là địa nó giữ nguyên cái
vùng mà các bạn copy I
khi khoảng cách là gì nó sẽ xóa cái dữ
liệu trước đấy đi nhá Đấy Ok tìm các thứ
ba là undo Thì bây giờ mình muốn undo
Tức là mình muốn quay lại cái thao tác
vừa xong tôi là cái thao tác vừa xong là
chẳng hạn là nhầm đúng không Thì mình sẽ
dùng các phím tắt undo là cần z để các
bạn sẽ ấn cần xét lại đây đấy thì như
vậy cái vùng dữ liệu mình cắt lúc đấy nó
đã quay về đây Đây là cái phím tắt để
undo nhá chẳng hạn các bạn lại ấn cái
chương phép nữa thì cái việc Tết Lúc nãy
nó cũng ăn lưu tiếp đấy Đấy là cách phím
tắt Windows các bạn có thể bấm ít kết để
thoát cái vùng nhấp nháy này đấy thì
chắc thứ năm là địa find and replace hay
là gì à tức là các bạn tìm kiếm nhá còn
replete là thay thế thì giả sử mình muốn
tìm kiếm tất cả trong cái dữ liệu này có
chữ nào là gà không chẳng hạn thế nhá
các bạn sẽ ấn là cân ép đấy thì sau khi
các bạn ấn cân ép thì nó sẽ có một cái
cửa sổ là file andres hiện ra đúng không
Thì nó sẽ có hai cái thẻ này thả file
vào thẻ replays đấy Nếu như các bạn ấn
can chép thì nó sẽ vào cái kẹp file
ạ Bây giờ các bạn sẽ bấm Grow nhé Còn
nếu như các bạn bấm tăng trưởng hát thì
nó sẽ chuyển sang cái thẻ replay đúng ạ
Đấy thì đầu tiên mình rất là tìm kiếm
các mẹ các bạn ấn kahchan ép đấy sau đó
còn sinh nhập cái từ mà các bạn cần tìm
kiếm lại Ví dụ mình nhập cái chữ diện
Excel để hạ thế nhá Đấy bấm enter thì ở
đây nó sẽ hiện cái thông báo là không
tìm thấy cái chữ Excel là cả đúng không
phải gọi xem bấm ok bây giờ xử không
phải là chữ xem nhá và mình muốn tìm cái
chữ hiện mình muốn tìm chữ giả sử mình
tìm viết chữ hành hạ Thế nhá Để gọi
enter thấy thì nó sẽ vào cái ô đầu tiên
đã tìm thấy này Đây là chọn cả hàng và
cô Đúng không các bạn sẽ tích vào đây là
philex tìm được hàng tiếp theo là ấy tìm
tiếp theo Còn nếu như bạn muốn tìm kiếm
tất cả thì các bạn sẽ tích và cái file
này thì nó sẽ hiện tất cả cái kết quả
tìm kiếm ở dưới này nó ấy các bạn có thể
tích vào cái kết quả tìm kiếm nào thì
tùy các bạn nhá để họ sẽ lau lại Nếu như
các bạn ấn Thanh Xuân h thì nó sẽ chuyển
sang điện sang cái thẻ đi Tết
Ừ thì ở đây nó sẽ có 2 cái cửa sổ đầu
tiên là gì ạ Cái ô mà các bạn cần tìm
thấy ví dụ mình xóa cái chữ hàng này đi
Chẳng hạn bây giờ mình cần tìm cái chữ
việc mình thay đổi trữ dữ liệu thì hạn
thế nhá lại dữ liệu bằng cái chữ gì ạ Ví
dụ mình thay bằng cái Excel đấy mình tìm
kiếm nha Thì bạn sẽ thích vào cái file
này đấy thì nó sẽ tìm thấy cái dữ liệu ở
đây đấy thì các bạn sẽ thích và cái
replete nhá thì nó sẽ thay cái dữ liệu
bằng chữ cái xe này các bạn dịp Tết này
đấy bạn thấy chưa thì mới trữ dữ liệu ở
đây đã được thay bằng chữ Thiện gái anh
xem tiếp theo này nó sẽ tìm thấy cái chữ
dữ liệu ở đây nếu các bạn thích vào dịp
tết đi lại thì nó sẽ chuyển thành ra
Excel Còn nếu như các em thích vào đi
biết tôn thì nó cứ thấy cái chữ dữ liệu
thì nó sẽ chuyển thành cái xe về có
thích ở đây đấy thì ở đây cái cửa sổ này
nó thông báo diện nó sẽ không tìm thấy
cái chữ dữ liệu là cả nhé Bây giờ các
bạn sẽ thích Ok mình còn lâu lại đi Đấy
Bây giờ con sẽ bấm kahchan dép hai lần
Tức là mình sẽ ăn đu cái việc thay thế
dữ liệu bằng gái xe
bí ẩn cần cho Z2 lần đấy thì như vậy cái
dữ liệu ở đây và dữ liệu đây nó sẽ quay
trở lại nhá Bây giờ các bạn sẽ ấn càng
Trân hát này mình vẫn thay cái dữ liệu
bằng chữ cái xe nhưng mà mình sẽ tích
vào cái kết hôn Tức là nó sẽ thay thế
toàn bộ cứ thấy cái chữ dữ liệu thì nó
sẽ thay một cái xe các bạn tích vào đây
Đấy nó sẽ báo một cái cửa sổ là Diện Nó
sẽ thay thế hoàn toàn rồi thì nó sẽ tìm
thấy gì hay cái chữ dữ liệu thay bằng
gái xem để con sẽ bảo OK các bạn Grow
lại Đấy bây giờ các bạn sẽ bấm cần xét
nhé Để mình ăn đu lại cái việc vừa xong
khiến các tiếp theo là gì ạ sẽ là tạo và
bỏ filter đúng ạ thì giả sử mình có một
cái sĩ dữ liệu đây nhá thì để tạo các
filter là diện các bạn sẽ giữ cần trong
ship và bấm chữ L đấy các bạn thấy chưa
nó sẽ tạm của các phân tử ở đây và lúc
này các bạn có thể tùy chọn các cái danh
mục mà qua chọn nhá rồi đấy là cái phím
tắt của phim cơ Còn nếu như mà muốn bỏ
cái phim tơ này thì các bạn cũng bấm cần
chôn ship và quạt bấm chữ L nhá lại
em còn nếu như mà phim tô nữa thì cần
chuyên ship nợ Đấy Thế là mình muốn bật
Hay là mình bỏ tin cơ thể bạn giữ tiền
ship và ấn chữ L nhé phím tắt tiếp theo
là mình sẽ di chuyển đến góp dữ liệu
đúng ạ thì giả sử nhá Mình đang ở cái ô
gì ạ ob6 Đây này các bạn muốn di chuyển
sang góp ở bên phải này thì các bạn giữ
cần chôn và có ấn xanh mũi tên bên phải
đấy thì nó sẽ sang cái góc dữ liệu ở bên
này là cái ô C6 là bây giờ cạn muốn lên
trên thì bạn giữ cần cho vào mũi tên lên
trên đấy thì nó sẽ lên cái ô D1 các bạn
muốn sang trái thì bạn giữ gần chung là
mũi tên Sang trái đây thì nó sẽ về cái A
một Còn nếu như bạn muốn sang góc dưới
bên trái thì bạn dưới Cần chôn vào mũi
tên xuống vào đây đấy Bạn thấy ạ đấy là
cái việc di chuyển góc nhé Tức là mình
sẽ sử dụng các phím control và bốn cái
mũi tên lên xuống hay là trái phải nhá
thì nó sẽ sang góc của các bạn cần ấn Ví
dụ mình cần chôn và mũi tên lên lại thì
nó sẽ lên trên cần chôn mũi tên xuống
thì nó là xuống đấy cần chuông xanh
ở đó là sang Góc ở đây Nếu như các bạn
ấn cần cho hôm thì nó sẽ quay về nha Một
này các bạn cần cho hôm đấy thì nó sẽ về
cái ô A1 là ô đầu tiên của cái xếp phím
sát tiếp theo là diện cho các ô trong
bảng thì nó khác gì mới cả di chuyển nếu
như bạn giữ thêm khiến sĩ chị thì nó là
chọn lại Bây giờ mình sang cái sẽ dữ
liệu Giả sử mình vẫn đang ở ob6 này nhá
Nếu như các bạn giữ cần chôn ship và mũi
tên Sang phải thì nó sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ
từ cái ôm mình chọn xanh cái góc ở đây
tức là điện từ B6 đến diện đến B6 Còn
nếu như các bạn giữ tiền cho chip và mũi
tên xuống dưới nữa nhé đấy thì nó sẽ lựa
chọn toàn bộ từ trên xuống dưới ở đây
đấy Còn nếu như mà diện các bạn rất cần
cho ship vào mũi tên Sang trái hả Thế
nhá thì nó lại lại lựa chọn sang bên
trái này Đấy Ok Bây giờ các bạn giữ cần
chôn và cần chuông vào hôm thì nó sẽ về
một đúng không ạ Bây giờ có bạn rất cần
cho ship và Mũi Tên Xanh gì ạ chẳng phải
đấy thì nó sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ như cùng
tiêu đề đây các bạn giữ cần trang ship
vào mũi tên xuống dưới nó sẽ lựa chọn
toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu
các bạn giữa cả chân ship và mũi tên lên
thì nó sẽ bỏ các lựa chọn đi và nó chỉ
chọn lại cái cục tiêu đề đây thôi đấy
rất là hai ạ phím tắt tiếp theo là di
chuyển giữa các sheet nhé thì giả sử
Mình đang ở cái sít đây là ship phím tắt
đúng không Bây giờ để di chuyển sang cái
ship bên phải nó thì có bạn sẽ giữ cần
chôn và tuyết down Còn nếu như mà di
chuyển sang bên trái thì các bạn sẽ giữ
cần chôn và huyết áp Bây giờ mình đang ở
sim đầu tiên đúng không Mình muốn sang
cái sim bên phải thế Bạn giữ cần chôn và
các bạn ấn kết đau đấy cần chung kết ra
đấy Bây giờ muốn quay lại các sĩ ở bên
trái các bạn giữ control và huyết áp đấy
cần suông kết hợp đấy Đấy là các phím
tắt để di chuyển giữa các sheet nhá tiếp
theo là gì định dạng số nhá Giả sử mình
có một cái số các bạn bằng này Ví dụ
mình lấy là một triệu đi một triệu cho
nhiều nha các bạn chia cho 3 đấy thì nó
sẽ ra kết quả là 333333 đấy Đấy nó còn
dư nữa cơ đấy thì đầu tiên là thiện mình
sẽ là bấm phần chương chín muồi cho nha
các bạn sẽ thích
khi mà các bạn muốn đi nhận số này các
bạn giữ cần ship một vào đây đấy thì cái
cần cho sếp một nó sẽ chuyển cái số này
về cái gì ạ dạng ăn cắt hàng nghìn với
nhau đợi tưởng ở đây 333.000 không thì
nó sẽ thêm cái dấu phẩy ở đây và nó sẽ
lấy hai cái số thập phân sau số nguyên
tức là chấm bà bà đây này Đấy còn thấy
thôi Còn nếu như bạn dưới Cần ship và số
2 Đấy thì nó sẽ chuyển về dạng viện dạng
giờ đây đấy gọi thấy chưa nó sẽ quy về 8
giờ em ở đây các bạn giữ cần cho ship và
số 3 thì nó sẽ chuyển về dạng ngày tháng
đấy tiếp theo làn diện các bạn giữ cần
ship và số 4 nhá thì nó sẽ đổi về cái
dạng tiền tệ của Mỹ ở đây này tức là nó
sẽ thêm các ký tự đô la đây nhá đấy Còn
nếu như mà cần chôn xuống năm ấy lại thì
nó sẽ chuyển về dạng Phần trăm đúng ạ
thì lúc đấy là dễ lúc đấy là 333.000
đúng không Thì ở đây nó sẽ đổi thành địa
33333333 phần trăm đấy tức nào nó sẽ
thêm với phần trăm ở đây đấy đấy là cái
năm cái định dạng số nhá Ừ
Anh xóa đi tiếp theo là tính tổng đấy
thì giả sử Mình đang ở cái ô dữ liệu này
nhá đấy các bạn ấn cần chôn rẻ và mũi
tên xuống thì nó sẽ xuống cái cuối cùng
của đây Bây giờ các bạn sẽ xuống cái ô
giấy này nhá các bạn giữa ăn và dấu bằng
đấy thì nó là cái phím tắt của cái việc
tính tổng xong ở đây để thì tức là nó sẽ
tính tổng từ vị đầu tiên là D2 đến viện
D 9998 đây này để họ sẽ bấm enter thì nó
sẽ là khiến tắt của tính tổng đấy nhá
Đấy đấy là cái kính thức ăn bằng tiếp
theo là dáng giá trị nhé đấy thì bây giờ
có bạn xanh cái sĩ dữ liệu này Bây giờ ở
đây nó đang là công thức đúng không Bây
giờ mình sẽ chuyển nó về giá trị mình
không muốn nói là công thức nữa đúng
không Chỉ đầu tiên các bạn phải copy
trước nha các bạn ấn cả cho C để các bạn
copy ôm này và nếu như mà để biết giá
trị Giả sử mình kết ra đây trở nặng thế
nhá thế thì các bạn sẽ bấm thì các bạn
dựa Nash và V Đấy thì nó sẽ hết thành
cái giá trị ở đây và bạn sẽ bấm ok đấy
nó sẽ viết thành các giá trị này lại rất
là hai ạ
đi tìm tắt tiếp theo là Chèn ngày giờ
hiện tại đó các bạn sẽ tích vào ô mà các
bạn cần chèn cái ngày giờ hiện tại và
các bạn giữ cần chôn ship và dấu chấm
phẩy nhá cần cho ship Bà Rịa chấm phẩy ở
đây thì nó sẽ ra là gì bây giờ hiện tại
ở đây nhá Còn nếu như các bạn giữ cần
chôn và gọi tấn chấm phẩy thì nó sẽ ra
ngày hiện tại đấy thì như vậy là gì cần
chôn và chấm phẩy nó sẽ ra ngày hiện tại
và điện Cần chôn ship chấm phẩy nó sẽ ra
diện giờ hiện tại là rất là hay luôn
tiếp theo là tạo một dòng mới trong một
oxir chú ạ thì các bạn sẽ giữ an và +
enter Ví dụ ở đây mình sẽ ghi là hiện
thực đơn giản thế nhé Bây giờ ta sẽ hai
chấm bây giờ các bạn muốn tạo một cái
dòng mới hiện vẫn trong cái ông này thì
bạn dưới phim an và các bạn ở Master đấy
Bây giờ mình sẽ liệt kê ví dụ như là
muối Chạm thế nhá lại là 2kg các bạn
giữa ăn và ấn enter lại Ví dụ ở đây là
rễ gạo gạo là diện 5kg để cạnh giữa ăn
và enter hãy cận cảnh cái ví dụ như thịt
lợn nặng thế
Ừ nếu ở một yến hả Thế nhá Đấy và các
enter lại đấy là cái phím tắt để các bạn
các bạn xuống dòng trong 1 ô lại Bây giờ
mình sẽ xóa đi nhá phím tắt tiếp theo là
việc chọn dữ liệu trong vùng Hiện tại
thì bây giờ giả sử mình đang tích và cái
ôm này nhá bây giờ mình muốn chọn dữ
liệu cả cái vùng này đúng không Chỉ rõ
sẽ ấn Corona đây nó sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ
cái vùng dữ liệu liên tiếp của Cái ô này
còn nếu như các bạn ấn canh chưa một lần
nữa thì nó sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ các sếp
này Đấy đấy là cái việc mà mình lựa chọn
nhé tiếp theo là diện là chèn cái đồ thị
tự động đúng ạ thì cái để chèn cái đồ
thị tự động thì các bạn sẽ bấm cái phím
Oppo F1 Ok Giả sử đây là cái vùng dữ
liệu của mình nhá Bây giờ mình sẽ xóa
ngay tính tổng này đi đã nhé Bây giờ các
bạn chỉ cần ấn An F1 nó sẽ vẽ đồ thị phi
động ở đây Các ạ bấm An F1 này đấy thì
nó sẽ các bạn chờ một lát nhé vì ở đây
thì dữ liệu của mình hơi nhiều gái gọi
thấy chưa thì nó sẽ vẽ cái đồ thị doanh
thu ở đây đây à
các dữ liệu nó rất là nhiều đúng không
Thì nó sẽ bị trả như thế này Đấy đấy là
cái phím tắt để các bạn vẽ đồ thị nhé
bây giờ để cắt thì bạn nhấn phải có bạn
cắt đi thôi đấy chúng ta tiếp theo là
mình chọn cả hàng không ạ chả sử mình
chọn cả cái hàng thứ 18 này nhá thì bạn
sẽ bấm nhẹ Các bạn bấm phím ship và các
bạn ấn pei đấy thì nó sẽ lựa chọn cả
hàng không ạ Bây giờ còn 4 lựa chọn
nhiều hàng nha ví dụ mình Bôi đen thế
này Thế là mình sẽ modem năm cái ô liên
tiếp nhé thì các bạn giữ shippingspace
thì nó sẽ lựa chọn 5 cái hàng luôn cho
các bạn đấy thì tương tự cái phím tắt mà
lựa chọn cả cột nha Thì là cardspace bạn
nếu như bạn muốn chọn cả các cuộc C này
nhá vì các bạn thích của một ô bất kỳ
của cột C sau đó gọi ấn cardspace thì nó
sẽ lựa chọn cả cái cột C này đấy Nếu như
các bạn Bôi đen hay cô bất kỳ của cột b
và cụ nghe nha các bạn ấn cardspace thì
nó xem lựa chọn hai cái cột này cột b và
cùng anh luôn đấy phím tắt tiếp theo là
chè hàng thì các bạn giữ cần ship vào
dấu cộng nhá thì sau đó ấn phím nghe Rồi
bây giờ giả sử mình chèn khách hàng ở
em xem cái hàng ở trước cái hàng 19 này
và sau cái hàng 18 này đúng không đấy
thì bạn tích vào Cái ô này và các bạn ấn
cao siêu chip vào dấu cộng nhá Đấy thì
nó sẽ hiện của cái cửa sổ lại insta và
các bạn gõ trị r vào đây Đấy thì nó sẽ
xuống cái này là em thay đâu và bạn sẽ
thích ok và các bạn bấm em tôi nhá Đấy
thì nó sẽ chèn một cái hàng ở giữa cái
hàng 18 và 19 bây giờ có bạn sẽ cần xét
để có ẩn vô lại nhá Bây giờ sửa Bạn muốn
chèn hai cái hàng thì ăn cái ví dụ mình
chèn hai cái Hành Giữa cái Hằng thứ ba
và thứ tư là đi thì các bạn sẽ Baron 2 ô
từ cái hàng thứ 5 đấy hàng thứ sáu nhé
các bạn cần ship vào dấu cộng ở đây sau
đó bạn bấm vào chữ R lại sẽ Các bạn bấm
ok thì nó sẽ chèn hai cái hàng ở đây cho
các bạn đúng ạ bây giờ qua sẽ cần sương
rét còn lưu lại tương tự là chèn cột thì
các bạn nó sẽ giống như chè hàng thì
thay vì bấm phím R thì bạn bấm phím c r
là dâu là hàng còn C là khó lần là cột
đấy thì bây giờ giả sử mình chán cái cột
giữa cột b và một xe thì bạn sẽ thích
thì các bạn cần ship vào dấu cộng đấy
thì nó sẽ hiện các cửa sổ và các bạn bấm
C ở đây tức là mình sẽ chèn cột Đúng
không các bạn xem bấm Ok vậy thì như vậy
nó sẽ chặn cái cổ đây đúng không ạ Bây
giờ mình cần xét đi giả sử mình cần chèn
hai cái cột giữa của B = 1C Đúng không
các bạn sẽ Model 2 ô bất kỳ của cây cột
C và cuộn đây này sau đó bạn giữ cần
ship vào dấu cộng Các bạn bấm DC đấy thì
nó sẽ thèm nó sẽ chèn hai cái cột giữa
của B và QC phải có thể uống rất là hai
ạ Bây giờ mình ăn nung á Cái thương dép
phím tắt tiếp theo là mình sẽ xóa hàng
và cột ấy thì mình sẽ dùng các phím
control + ngay cả dấu trừ đúng ạ Bây giờ
giả sử mình chèn hai cái cột ngang giữa
cuộc đời của một xe của thằng bạn sẽ
Baron 2 cái ô ở cột C của búp bê các bạn
ấn canxi tố + Các bạn bấm phím C để chèn
cột này Bây giờ mình muốn xóa cái cột C
và cột bên này đúng không các bạn sẽ bấm
cancel và dấu trừ đang chôn dấu trừ đấy
thì nó sẽ hiện của cái cửa sổ Đây gọi là
cửa sổ Delete Thế là mình sẽ chọn cái
kiểu bao nhiêu lít nếu như bạn muốn xóa
cột thì bạn sẽ bấm C
chị sẽ là rõ cột Còn nếu các bạn bấm
nghe rồi thì nó là xóa hàng đúng không
Thì trong trường hợp này mình muốn xóa
cái cột C và búp bê Đúng không các bạn
sẽ nhấn c Đấy và các bạn Bống enter Hoặc
là các bạn thích ok ở đây cũng được đấy
thì nó sẽ xóa hai cái cụt bây giờ để
chèn hàng em mình sẽ Bôi đen 3 đấy hả
Thế các bạn cần chôn ship vào dấu cộng
Các bạn bấm nghe rồi thì nó sẽ là tiền
hạn đúng không Bây giờ mình muốn xóa ba
cái hàng này thì bạn giữ cần chôn và các
bạn ấn vào - đấy và bạn gõ chữ L là nó
sẽ xóa hàng nó các bạn thân bấm ok đấy
là cách xóa hàng nhé tiếp theo là diện
chuyển hàng sang một hàng khác đúng
không ạ thì bạn giữ chuột trái cắn ship
rồi có thả đấy Bây giờ giả sử mình diện
hai cái thủ thuật này nhá Mình muốn đẩy
lên diện đẩy lên trước cái thủ thuật di
chuyển ca sĩ ở đây đúng không chỉ các
Model hai cái thủ thuật này để các bạn
Vấn đề cái số thứ tự nha tại vì mình
muốn cái số thứ tự nó như thế này nó
không dịch chuyển đúng không mình chỉ di
chuyển cái vùng mà mình Bôi đen thôi
đúng không các bạn giữ chuột trái và
phím ship đấy các bạn giữ chuột trái và
kiếm ship sau đó bạn kéo lên
em lên trước cái thủ thuật mà các bạn bị
chèn đúng không Tớ là cái thủ thuật thứ
9 là di chuyển giữa các sheet này và khi
nó hiện cái dấu gạch động ấy thì bạn sẽ
nhà tuyệt chảy ra đấy sau đó gọn Minh
thả khiến ship ra đấy bạn thấy cho thì
hai cái thủ thuật này nó được chèn trước
cái thủ thuật di chuyển giữa các xí luôn
đấy cảm thấy cũng rất là hai ạ Bây giờ
bạn sẽ bấm cần z để undo đấy là cái việc
phải di chuyển nhé di chuyển cũng vậy
bây giờ giả sử mình muốn chuyển cái cột
b này sang so với cụ c này chẳng hạn thế
nhá thì mình là như thế nào mình sẽ tích
và cả cái cột b đúng không ạ Đấy các bạn
sẽ di chuyển vào một cách chặn bất kỳ ở
đây khi mà nó hiện cái mũi tên sẽ ra bốn
bên Thế còn giữ kín ship nhé các bạn
ship là kéo sang đây đấy Đấy nó sẽ hiện
của cái đường sọc giữa của C và cột b
thì các bạn thể bỏ cái chuột trái ra thì
sau đó qua cái vỏ phím ship đấy thì như
vậy mình đã hoán đổi giữa cột C và cột
bên đấy là nếu không rất là hai ạ Bây
giờ các bạn dự tính phải tương xét nhé
mình sẽ vui lắm đấy chúng ta
a nguyên xác định hàng và cột đúng ạ thì
để ẩn hàng thì các bạn sẽ ấn cần chôn và
số 9 cẩn cột thì có sẽ ấn cần chung vào
số không Bây giờ giả sử mình muốn ẩn cột
đi nhá Ví dụ mình ẩn cái cột C này thì
các bạn sẽ lìa ấn control vào số không
đấy thì nó sẽ ẩn cái cục này đúng ạ Bây
giờ bạn sẽ cần tránh rét để mình ăn đu
lại bây giờ để hàng nha ví dụ như Ẩn
khách hàng thứ 24 là nhá đây thì các bạn
giữ cần chun và gọi là số 9 đấy thì nó
đã ẩn cái hàng thứ hai bốn này lại cảm
thấy ông rất là hay bây giờ còn từ tương
dép lại nhá thì để nhiều cột Ví dụ mình
ẩn cái cột b và một xe này nha các bạn
sẽ poland hay ô bất kỳ của cột b và cột
C đúng không các bạn giữ diện các bạn ấn
càng chun và số không đấy thì nó sẽ ẩn
cả cái cột b và QC lại rất là hay bây
giờ mình cần xét lại ví dụ để ẩn 4 cái
Hạnh này thì các bạn xem bodil40 ô bất
kỳ của cái hàng này đúng không Sau đó
bạn diện ấn cái chuông số 9 đấy thì nó
sẽ Ẩn toàn bộ các khách hàng mà có lựa
chọn ở trên đúng không ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ
lưu lại đây là cái phím tắt để nhận hàng
và cột nhá chúng ta tiếp theo
Vì sao nhìn thấy mình sẽ sử dụng cái
phím An + chấm phẩy nhá Bây giờ giả sử
mình ăn cái cột C này đi nhá thì các bạn
rẻ cạn dưới control và số không Đấy là
mình ảnh cái cột C này Bây giờ mình ẩn
tiếp là ví dụ diện mình vẫn tiếp cái
hàng thứ 21 này nhá thì bạn gì À cần
chôn một số 9 thì như vậy mình ngẩn cái
hàng 21 và thì cái cột C bây giờ mình để
lựa chọn các xem nhìn thấy đây là tất cả
các xe này là sao nhìn thấy đúng không
các bạn sẽ bấm gì An chấm phẩy đấy thì
nó Lựa Chọn toàn bộ các cái Sao nhìn
thấy còn những diện những cái hàng ẩn và
những cục ẩn Chúng là những Excel và họ
không nhìn thấy đây này Đấy thì nó sẽ
không lựa chọn thì cái phím an và cái
chấm phẩy đây thì họ sẽ biết được làm
thiệt cái hàng nào là Cột nào đang ẩn
đây còn nhìn thấy đây các bạn biết ngay
là cái cục C nhà và cái hàng thứ 19 được
ạ Để Thì đấy là cái công dụng để mình có
thể biết được là cái hàng và cô nào bí
ẩn nhá Đấy mình sẽ dùng cái pin mình sử
dụng các phím An + chấm phẩy dài gọn
thích vào đây Bây giờ bạn bấm không rét
để undo cái việc ẩn lại vừa xong nhá
phím tắt Cuối Cùng là điền nha
A gọi là phát phiêu thì các bạn vào cái
xi ba này nhá giả sử ở đây Mình có họ
này tên này Bây giờ mình sẽ lấy thành
cái tên đầy đủ đúng không Thì cái
freshview này Khánh hay các bạn chỉ cần
nhập một cái thôi ở đây ví dụ đây là
Nguyễn Văn An đúng là cao thì gõ đầy đủ
là Nguyễn này Văn A đấy Sau đó thì các
bạn sẽ bấm cần trước E là được đấy Bạn
thấy chưa thì nó sẽ hiểu là diện nó sẽ
Flashtool rất là nó sẽ biến nhanh cho
toàn bộ với danh sách còn lại tức là nó
sẽ gộp cái dữ liệu của cột a và cột bên
ạ ạ đấy còn thấy không rất là hai ạ Cái
flash này gọi chú ý nhé Nó chỉ có từ cái
phiên bản Excel 2013 thôi nếu các bạn mà
cài kỹ cho bạn cũ hơn thì nó sẽ không có
cái class này đâu nhé Đấy Ok như vậy là
mình đã kết thúc bài học ngày hôm nay ở
đây cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi các bạn
nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập nhật video mới
nhất của gà cũng như chia sẻ để giúp mọi
người cùng học ít sao nhé Xin chào và
hẹn gặp lại à
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]